OF THE GOAL DEFLECTED WIDE BY
WILSON.
OVECHKIN NEXT TALLY  NICE, LITTT
FROM PBR.
A DEFLECTION IN FRONT.
WILSON AND OVI
SHEARY, ON ICE FOR WASHINGTON.
TRYING TO BACKUP THE GOAL
THAT'S BEEN CREDITED TO TOM WAS
EXQUISITE.
THAT WAS THEIR BEST OPPORTUNITY
WE'VE SEEN IN
CITY THIS THE CALL FROM CAPS
EXECUTIVE CHCH 12-6 ICE.
>>LINEUP FOR
HIS FIRST GAME AND IT LOOKED
MAY
EAKIN THE FORMER CAPITALS
CAPTAIN.
CARLSON.
NO CHANCE FOR HIM TO MAKE SURE
HE GETS CLOSERFOR
WASHINGTON IS HENDRIX LAPIERRE
ALONG WITH DENNIS CHOLOWSKI AND
MATT IRWIN.
MOVING
DID.
IT'S ON THIS PLAY  TOKARSKI.
AXEL JONSSON-FJALLBY OUT T TTHE
>> Craig: ALL SOMEHOW IT SABREN
DOWN THE BACKHAND,OVES HIS FEET
WHICH CREATES OFFEGOALS IN
THREE OF ITS IT THERE FOR  FAKE
NOT THE HARDEST SHOT YOU'LL
EVER SEE.
GOES RIGHT PASS THE
GOALTENDER'S CATCHINSTICK UP AN
HIS  DOESN'T PICK IT UP.
LOOK AT THE BEND ON  STRETCH, S
KNIFING IN.
SKININ LANDS RIGHT ON HIS SHOUL
HE DIDN'T